tonight on clock ticking on a screen
will investigate the question that has
been baffling limited Spanish speakers
for generations that's right we will
finally answer donde esta la biblioteca
I began my search at the place with the
biggest concentration of people who've
taken seven years of Spanish and forgot
it Brooklyn New York although this was a
traditionally spanish-speaking
neighborhood it seemed to me that things
had changed no one seemed to have an
answer and I was stuck so I decided to
ask an expert this is Ken Bray Bray has
spent his entire adult life obsessively
trying to figure out donde esta la
biblioteca ken is also an expert at
Midway there's a good thing they can be
more over on knee breeches do you guys
mind doing the people take a walk and
talk okay thank you dubbing yeah it's
fine thank you many consider Ken the
premier biblioteca expert while others
think he's a conspiracy theorist gone
mad he also happens to have the voice of
a sweet vulnerable Nightingale la
bibliothèque hmm so Ken you've spent
your entire adult life searching for la
people Atika are you any closer to
finding it of course the signs are
everywhere open your eyes
I'm sorry I want you to look at this
dollar do you notice anything no how
about if I take this dollar and I fold
it three times now what do you see a
Dorito a symbol for love biblioteca have
you seen this symbol before I can't say
that I have no I've seen the inside of a
dictionary above of course everybody has
the same symbol
have you seen Cool Runnings I have it's
been sitting on my DVR for like three
weeks and I can't find time to watch it
you're most everybody keeps telling me
to help lifting up lifting yet comedic
cuba gooding cuba gooding mmm he's not
in that I didn't know what to
believe so I decided to go straight to
the source
where it all began now mrs. Lopez you've
taught Spanish for 25 years is that
right yes it is my lifelong passion
wonderful now isn't it true that the
first thing that you teach your students
is donde esta la biblioteca yes it's
important to know me wonderful know
where is lobby latekka me syllabus oh I
don't know would you like a cookie
really shouldn't this is Lopez where'd
you get that tattoo what's going on here
hold on this interview is over
your English is impeccable woman I know
that symbol the people deserve to know
the truth el Bano esta Frio mo Carlitos
tiene alguno Oh bathrooms and puppies
hey what do they have to do with one
another
logically it doesn't make any sense I'm
gonna get to the bottom of this uh-uh-uh
en espanol ok agita voyage agar fondo al
fondo there sir
muy bien you're a dead man you're a dead
man I had to figure out how it was all
connected
so I gathered every resource I could oh
I knew I had to go deeper that monkey is
evil Dora and we both know it and like
any good reporter I decided to use my
surroundings and interview one of mrs.
Lopez's students do you know where I can
find la bibliothèque oh why don't you
just ask a Spanish person shitty Bruno
Mars you're right
thank you dick so do you know where la
bibliothèque is la bibliothèque 'ah yes
of course it's right over oh not again
[Music]
mrs. Lopez stop that stay right there
mrs. Lopez it looks like for now the
whereabouts of Lobby Bottega will remain
unknown excuse me sir can you wrap it up
the library's closing in five minutes
oh I'm so sorry I'll strike the time
let's wrap it up boys all of you I can
see in you two
you're part of my crew tonight on
solving things in a trench coat will
examine the disappearance of Walter
oedema also we'll find out Kian is pablo
and why is he always by love playa
tune in yeah exits this way
[Music]
you